hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
for monday
january 31st 2022
[Music]
two what's going on how are you
how's it going huh you back east was
there a [ __ ] nor easter dude
dude it's a [ __ ] perfect storm
you got a westerly wind coming off the
lake and [ __ ] buffalo filled with the
frozen tears of their [ __ ] fans after
they choked away the [ __ ] game last
week
dude i didn't choke it away it was a
[ __ ] coin flip well whatever dude
they should have said heads
that [ __ ] water
came right over [ __ ] lee
massachusetts [ __ ] exit 2 off the
[ __ ] mass turnpike
it got caught up and wealthy
they always make such a big [ __ ] deal
about the goddamn snow and they're
always looking at the drifts
look at that door jesus christ look at
that door in the corner of that building
well it's got to be up to your neck you
have a look at the snow around it
all that i saw
was was manageable
situations
okay
it's manageable everything is manageable
you wait you [ __ ] wait
i'm not saying it wasn't a bad storm i
wasn't even out there i was out here in
the sunshine baby i was enjoying myself
how is it back east huh
you got your little ice scraper out
that [ __ ] dead [ __ ] back and forth
sound
oh my god
i remember that coming out there
the crunch of the [ __ ] snow and ice
under your boots
my car isn't going to start i know it's
not going to start looking it's wrapped
in a [ __ ] cocoon of snow
dude i need a job right and you finally
get the [ __ ] thing going and your ass
would be on that cold [ __ ] vinyl seat
you know
and the best part was when your best
part of starting your car
was when it was warm enough
that could you you could actually go
back inside
you know and just let the [ __ ] engine
run
and let it get all [ __ ] warmed up
you know i mean i just take pride in
clearing the snow off my car i clean the
whole [ __ ] thing off
you know i wouldn't just clean it off
like the the [ __ ] windshield
you know i love people who'd like clean
off the whole car and then just leave
the roof like a [ __ ] you know a kid
and play haircut except with snow
they just go flying down the street it
was like it was snowing all over again
for the people behind you
um
nice clean the whole [ __ ] off
and uh
yeah that was the best
once it got warm enough that you could
actually go in the house
and just sit there
then stare at your car and make sure
nobody took it
you know what i mean who the [ __ ] would
want an 83 ford ranger four speed vinyl
seats no air conditioning with a factory
radio the long bed
huh
the big [ __ ] dent in the tailgate
filled with some bondo
um because your dad said he knew how to
fix it
oh yeah i can do it how you do that
bollywood
um
yeah i do not miss that
the only thing great about snow is when
you're a kid and you don't have to go to
school
that was the [ __ ]
you know then you paid for it in june
because you had to make up the days or
whatever but all i know out here
it was lovely
it was lovely i went down to uh i went
into hollywood something i never do
just being the older fella that i am
which i kind of love being old is this
[ __ ] by the way
don't let any of these [ __ ] real
housewives or these [ __ ] guys you
know
the new thing now is they show you know
it used to be the real housewives right
where they would just show like you know
you can still have perky tits in your
50s
and you know a wrinkled free
shiny sweaty looking face whatever the
[ __ ] that is you know looking like you
just got out of a steam room some people
find that attractive i guess i don't
know
um
they're now starting to do that with
guys they're having all of these like
[ __ ] shredded older guys
and they're just sitting there with sad
pecs staring down at the floor like they
don't want to fight anybody
and then all of a sudden you know then
they do the after picture
and the guy is just [ __ ]
jacked
did a [ __ ] cycle they're all doing us
there's no [ __ ] way
ira there's no diet and there's no
[ __ ] workout for you to get that
[ __ ] shredded and put that amount of
muscle on in your 50s you can't [ __ ]
do it you cannot [ __ ] do it do i have
any medical background no i don't this
doesn't stop me i'll pontificate all i
want
you know what my research is being a 53
year old man
yeah that's it your shoulders give out
everything's done it's a [ __ ]
rap you're in your 50s you're in your
yoga years you start having soup and
salad
all right you're going easy you're
babying the engine so you can still get
up the [ __ ] hill they got these
[ __ ] 63 year olds running up the
hills carrying logs
like they're trying to become a [ __ ]
green beret or some [ __ ] i'm not buying
it
you know what's funny
is to see a shredded [ __ ] hair
plugged guy in his 60s saying barry
bonds doesn't belong in the hall
[Music]
so write it up guy
um
i do find that fascinating
people wanting to continue to be
[ __ ]
well into i don't know how i don't
understand it once you have kids all you
want to do is just sleep
like i get you know i understand now why
couples after a while they sleep in
separate rooms
you know what i mean
it doesn't mean the marriage is over
you've just reached a level of maturity
like look
look look what banging didn't you know
we got this beautiful family and now
we're just tired
all right how about you have your own
bed
you know and you can
sprawl out and snore and do whatever you
want i can be down the hall muttering
and grinding my teeth or whatever the
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] i do
then we'll wake up the morning see each
other absence making the heart grow
funner somebody's always going to wake
up earlier
right
um
i don't know what i'm talking about i
never do
i never do but i'm calling [ __ ] i'm
calling [ __ ]
on these [ __ ] like it's one thing if you
if you just kept working out
i'll give it with those guys but those
guys that let themselves go
and they got like a dad bod and all of
that [ __ ] and then dude i'm talking
more shredded
than most people are ever shredded
in their lives
coming back like roger clemens on the
[ __ ] blue jays
right like i thought he was done all of
a sudden it's 1984 again what happened
um
anyway
um
did i tell you i did barry bonds get in
i think barry bond should get into the
hall i know i've been making this
argument forever i really believe
that barry bonds was a victim of the
steroids era
i really do because he was the guy and
then a bunch of other people cheated and
then the president was calling them
instead of barry and then barry was like
well all right [ __ ] it then
you know this is me on steroids
there's 73 mark
right
barry bonds hall of fame opponents
can't handle the truth barry bonds and
roger clemens got what they deserved
[Music]
could david ortiz's endorsement get
bonds roger clemens into the hall of
fame this is the amazing thing about all
those baseball players and all of those
people that took steroids
is what what they learned on those
people's bodies they're now using on
[ __ ] 50-something-year-old white
dudes like me so we can be [ __ ]
shredded
[Music]
[Laughter]
after our second and third divorce and
go down to what apple's bees and maybe
have a shot
you're 63 god i only thought you were
51.
just go down there all these [ __ ]
chicks with daddy issues
um
yeah and my buddies one of my buddies
from back home not in the business an
original og friend of mine he said it he
said he steroids saved baseball baseball
was [ __ ]
all of their records were from in the
past
they canceled the world series they had
nothing all they had was cal ripken jr
breaking lou gehrig's record that's all
they [ __ ] had thank god the yankees
came back that was great for baseball
i wouldn't say all was right as they say
and at least some people that all was
right it was great for baseball you know
it's it's great for baseball when when
like it's like the 49ers 49ers being
[ __ ] good again it's good you know
you don't want to see them suck i'll get
into that in a minute um
but anyway
i always thought barry bonds was just
like you know
all of these guys were going to hit more
home runs and be more dominant during
his time
and the reality is if all of them were
natural they couldn't touch barry and
then they all cheated right and bill
clinton
right
the old cigar smoker himself called up
sosa and maguire instead of barry bonds
so they he was like all right well [ __ ]
it then is that that's this is this the
new world is this the new normal
uh that guy would hit over 500 home runs
easy which is hall of fame [ __ ]
numbers enough already
enough already and then you look at them
they're [ __ ] all over pete rose for
betting on baseball right
then that was like the big taboo and now
look at him you can gamble right there
at the [ __ ] ballparks on the game as
as fans though still what pete rose did
you know he was actually playing in the
[ __ ] game
you know um
here's what i want to commission i want
to stop calling the 1919
uh white sox the black sox
i want them to be called the white sox
so everybody knows what franchise did it
because for the longest time i always
thought the black socks were some
defunct [ __ ] team
you know that threw the world series and
then their fans sort of left them
and then they you know
it just faded away right like the canton
bulldogs or something in ohio
not saying they cheated they weren't
like at the beginning of the af all
right bill shut the [ __ ] up okay fine i
will shut up i will shut up but i won't
shut up because i don't have any guests
on this thing at least not this week all
right
so let's talk
what everybody wants to talk about
neil young leaving spotify now
let's talk nfl player
[Music]
we can't talk neil young real quick i
saw they said that spotify's stock
lost four billion dollars because neil
young left or since neil young left and
i immediately thought to myself
no it didn't
you are now taking the numbers to make
it seem like something else right
because you got that whole big [ __ ]
battle you know the people that like a
certain podcast and those people that do
not like a certain podcast
right
so they were all one side was rooting
for neil young the other was rooting for
the podcast
and spotify chose the podcast and the
winner is the podcast
the podcast the podcast the puck not the
80 year old guy
um
so then all the neil young people
gotta act like
spotify took this major [ __ ] hit they
all fudged the numbers to make it look
everybody's just full of [ __ ] [ __ ]
i don't believe
any [ __ ] data
until this [ __ ] happened
and then you i just you just have the
stats and even then that only works in
[ __ ] sports
it does not work in other things because
then even after [ __ ] happens people put
their little spin on it and their little
[ __ ] numbers
you know
i gotta be honest with you that human
being instinct to want to win
over getting
the right answer
is a [ __ ] disease everybody has
including myself
how many times you've been in an
argument with your [ __ ] wife right
you know she's right and you're just
hanging in there because you don't want
to lose
and you're just making up [ __ ] you're
trying to [ __ ] make it about
something else just take the loss
know that she's right and go work on
yourself
i'm not even talking to you guys i'm
talking to myself here um
all right
so
well well well well well
the kansas city chiefs
all their fans were head over [ __ ]
hills
and holy [ __ ] the [ __ ] bengals beat
the titans and we get to play them is
we're gonna [ __ ] walk into that super
bowl
kelsey's gonna be moonwalking after
every catch tyreek hill is gonna happen
down a [ __ ] field
right patrick mahomes is gonna be
slinging its sidearm and underhanding
the baby down by the goal line all of
that was gonna [ __ ] happen
what did i say last week what did i say
about that buffalo cheese game huh now i
want to be right
this is a time where i want to feel like
i'm right
so i can sleep
a little a little better tonight knowing
that i was right about something in life
i told you guys last week that that
[ __ ] game against the bills and the
chiefs was the worst [ __ ] defense
i've seen in a major [ __ ] game in the
40 [ __ ] years i've been watching
football other than
the patriots verse the philadelphia
eagles it wasn't even football
think about the end of that game how
many great throws were they versus were
there versus wide-open [ __ ] receivers
cornerbacks falling down
tyreek hill's the only one i'll give you
because that guy is just he's just above
and beyond
you know he's just one of those guys you
throw a two-inch pass to him he's gonna
get the other 80 yards and there's
nothing you can do about it that one i i
will give you all [ __ ] day long
it was atrocious [ __ ] defense all
right
and you think how long do you think
you're gonna go
where your defense is so bad
that your big thing is is you got to win
a coin toss in overtime beca how many
weeks can you do that in playoffs before
it comes back and bite you in the
[ __ ] house how many [ __ ] times can
you do it
um well unfortunately
the uh kansas city chiefs which i didn't
realize they redid this they remodeled
their stadium i don't know if i i mean
it's nicer that they have the wider
[ __ ] spiral things down but like
um
i mean that stadium was just [ __ ]
iconic i mean that was the same [ __ ]
stadium from those nfl films
way back in the day
right after hank stram i believe
i think right after they won their super
bowl against the vikings
what was that 64 touched by trap uh that
[ __ ] game then they got arrowhead
stadium
beautiful [ __ ] stadium
um
but whatever
in comes
joe burr
from lsu
maybe the new cool joe on the block
the original cool joe
you know played with the four or the
49ers joe montana with bill walsh as we
all know who used to be the quarterback
coach for the bengals
do you realize the cincinnati bengals
could have been the 49ers in the 1980s
they had bill walsh they had ken
anderson they had isaac curtis they had
all of these [ __ ] guys
they had paul brown the original bill
belichick as their gm like
they were they were on their way
and
jim brown got rid of pete carroll
pete carroll goes to san diego then to
stanford and he comes back with the
49ers and the offense that he created
i'm going to keep saying this
the offense that he [ __ ] created in
cincinnati
after gary cook got injured and ended
his career and they had that virgil
what's his face with the weaker arm the
short quick passes he invented that
later became known as the west coast
offense he invented that
he invented that in cincinnati
the mel blunt rule was the amended isaac
curtis rule the cincinnati bengals
speedster
saying after five yards you can't keep
clutching and grabbing them
paul brown what's the point of having a
performer if he cannot perform
it's [ __ ] amazing i mean they are
such
a what if piece of nfl history they're
such a [ __ ] amazing
friend they hope right down to their
orange helmets which was paul brown's
[ __ ] you to the cleveland browns for
getting rid of him saying he was too old
he basically was trying to take their
colors as much as he could when they
first came in the league it was a plain
orange helmet just like the [ __ ]
browns which he got away with i believe
when they were in the afl but once they
went to the nfl he had to write bengals
on the side and then they finally went
with the [ __ ] tiger king stripes
um
anyways it's fascinating i keep talking
about you really have to look at
the history of the uh the cincinnati
bengals it's amazing and they are one
[ __ ] game away and who are they gonna
play
by the way by the way how about the
[ __ ] bengals playing defense and
kicking field goals hanging in there
hanging around hanging around
a couple of [ __ ] turnovers
right
next thing you know
old jed's a millionaire and and they got
the best field goal kicker and the new
field goal kicker in the [ __ ] nfl
and they're gonna play a home game
against the la ram
la rams who beat the the san francisco
49ers
huh did i call it or did i call it all
you 49er fan you just you keep lol you
keep missing the 49ers i [ __ ] i
wasn't buying it i knew you guys weren't
a super bowl team
i knew it because i haven't played
organized football since the third grade
i knew it i saw it i saw things
i was not aware however that the 49ers
beat the rams like the last seven times
in a [ __ ] row and i will tell you
this
i was way more impressed
with the cincinnati bengals their play
and their coaching than anything i saw
in that rams
49ers game as far as coaching goes
i thought both the rams
coach and the [ __ ] 49ers coach
kept getting cute in crucial moments
they were getting cute like pete carroll
give it to marshawn lynch let's get a
little cute here let's dial up a place
so i can seem clever
the coaching version of dropping the
ball spiking it before you [ __ ] cross
the goal line that pulling a [ __ ]
tackle and acting like we're running
there but we're really running her over
here stupid
and i know this
because i haven't even played tackle or
touch football in at least 20 years
you heard it here first people
if you want to know the ins and outs of
the nfl you need to listen to a 53 year
old white comedian
who after the game is over and sees what
worked and what didn't he can say why
did they do this why shouldn't he they
should have done that
um
so i guess what's her face uh joni
mitchell
it's kind of funny that all the neil
young
all the [ __ ] laurel candor canyon
singer songwriters
are [ __ ] walking away from spotify
who do you think's going to be next the
monkeys
mickey dollars he's the last guy
and the monkeys right and then i saw her
face right he's going to be the next one
[ __ ] out of here
um
um
i have just a zest of covered left i
just took another [ __ ] rapid test
and it was just the faintest
of the positive lines so i think by
tomorrow i should be all right
and then i should be good you know
and i think i did the right thing i
think i did the right thing you know i'm
now not calling it the vaccine
i'm calling it the shot i got the shot i
got both shots and i got the [ __ ]
i got the booster
you know and therefore the entire time i
had covet i i wouldn't even known i had
coveted if if i didn't have
a test if somebody didn't test positive
in my house i wouldn't even have known
that i had it i would have thought i had
a cold because i smoked too many [ __ ]
cigars that's how little
it affected me so i
i think i did
i did
what was right for me
that's what i believe
uh speaking of what's right for me is i
need to get [ __ ] back on stage
because i haven't been on stage in a
week
and my act will be week
come february 5th at fantasy springs i
got to make sure i go out so i'm going
to be doing a bunch of spots this week
in and around
um
los angeles going to be popping in here
or there but i got to be negative two
days in a row before i can go out that's
how it works
that's how it works you know
i'll tell you what's [ __ ] nuts
because i wanted to buy a cigar right
and i pulled up the car my wife was in
the car
and i was like i can't go in there
i'm like you know
even though i'm just
on the last day but like and they're
saying you know some people are saying
on the internet that at this point seven
days after you touch the positive you're
not [ __ ] contagious anymore with
omicron i can't [ __ ] go in there
i can't go in there right
and then i thought about it and then
whereas i was walking up the doors i
can't do this my wife's going yeah i
don't know like kenya
so i walked right up to the door and i
was just like ah i'm not doing it
the night before my daughter wanted a
pizza and i didn't have any pizza sauce
and i was like all right i'll run down
to the grocery
i can't i can't do it
i wanted to
i was gonna put on a mask and go in
there
you know me hold my breath when i walked
by people
to get pizza sauce be a selfish [ __ ]
decided not to
um
i decided not to
i probably should i don't know you know
i saw these [ __ ] young kids today
right they were going up and down
melrose we went down there to get some
you know ice cream or some [ __ ] outside
it was an outside [ __ ] event there
um oh no my wife tested negative so she
was able to go in
um i did not have any
i sat there like a sad old man
who's not on steroids so i couldn't take
it you know
bill why do you do steroids at 53 years
of age yeah i just love ice cream you
know and i still want to pay for it
[Laughter]
i want to see the first
60 year old roid rage
you know
just flips out and his 59 year old
girlfriend is just going like you know
he used to just be such a relaxed person
i told him there was nothing wrong with
his man boobs and he just told me that
he didn't feel good about himself so at
first he started doing steroids it was
fun that doesn't even happen anymore
thanks to all of these athletes
olympic professional and otherwise
who've all been taking that [ __ ] all the
way back to the [ __ ]
the 70s or whatever whenever it first
[ __ ] came out
now it's like a cream
you know you put it on like cbd
um
so anyway we're down to melrose and all
these [ __ ] kids were down there kids
i say kids you know in their 20s they
had like [ __ ] dirt bikes and four
wheelers like a group of six of them
with [ __ ] uh you know no helmets on
doing the wheelies going up and down the
street like that old [ __ ] dmx
you know stop
drop load up table up job whatever that
one was
uh let me look up see what happened
melrose
dirt bikes
cops
today
motorcycles calls cause mayhem on
melrose i was there
lapd makes six arrests confiscates
vehicles and a firearm i was [ __ ]
there oh that was the oh sorry sorry
sorry i was not there
that was june 12th
2021 the other one was april 28 20 i
thought i was there what about today
i searched today
five things to know about street
takeovers racing in la law enforcement
says groups of dirt bikes oh i like this
[ __ ]
anyway like [ __ ] six
of those lapd [ __ ] mom
soccer mom suv i really miss the
cruisers
you know can you give the guys a [ __ ]
goddamn
four-door sedan again those stupid
[ __ ]
you know i'm going to my
stripper pole dancing class [ __ ]
vehicles they give them five things to
know about street takeovers other types
of street racing in la why do i need to
know about this
why do i need to know about this
um
five things there are several different
types in addition in addition to
organized through illegal meetups among
people who know each other there are
also impromptu races between strangers
and sideshows with groups of people who
take over intersections to perform
stunts and street takeovers where dozens
of off-road vehicles take over a street
to ride recklessly
aren't they really just trying to get
more friends on instagram
uh dirt bikes street takeovers are
becoming more popular in los angeles it
started in south la a few years ago and
is now happening more frequently in the
central part of the city along melrose
avenue and la brea avenue i saw one of
those i saw a street take over
oh my god
i feel so young and and relevant
uh the increase in street racing with
off-road vehicles is being driven by
social media that makes it easy to
arrange and by the low cost of dirt
bikes
compared with cars well all the dirt
bikes got away and one the poor bastard
riding the four-wheeler he can see one
who got caught because he's basically
can't [ __ ] split lanes
um so there's one for you
that's a tip
for the reckless people dirt bike street
racing started in oakland
in the 1990s and was popularized in
baltimore maryland
is that right it started in oakland
didn't it start when the dirt bike
happened
you're telling me they had dirt bikes
all over the [ __ ] country and nobody
raced them
um traffic collisions my friends used to
[ __ ] do that all the
[Music]
[ __ ] in time
80s
yeah you'd ride it on the road and then
you'd [ __ ] cop and start chasing
they'd go into the woods
but i lived in a small town and then
they'd eventually just be sitting there
in front of the kid's house when he came
home
my mom took away my dirt bike uh traffic
collisions involving street racing have
tripled in la this year according to the
los angeles police department i can tell
you this they lapd was not [ __ ]
around they sent in like six cruisers
and a helicopter and all that i heard
this person go isn't that a little
excessive
don't you think that's a little
excessive and you know what happened if
one of those kids was doing a wheelie
and they wiped out and that bike flew
into the [ __ ] sidewalk and hit a kid
they would be like where was the police
presence
oh but they were all down in a donut
shop
um
it's one of the great things about
complaining as you can i mean god knows
i know all about that you can know
there's always an angle
there's always
a [ __ ] angle anyway congratulations
to the [ __ ] cincinnati bengals in the
la rams two home games in a row um
going to the super bowl
i thought it was going to be the rams
versus the chiefs i thought
i thought the bengals were going to hang
for a half
and then you know the chiefs were going
to do what they do which is score points
and not play defense i didn't realize
that the bengals were going to shut down
the kansas city chiefs i did not realize
that they were going to pick off patrick
mahomes
arguably
if tom brady retires the best guy the
best quarterback in the league
um twice who saw that coming definitely
not myself
and uh just a absolutely huge
huge huge victory that's so great for
that city man those people love
their [ __ ] bengals man um
great fans out there i remember doing
the funny bone out there and they would
get so [ __ ] amped up
for regular season games
um i still think that's the best
division as far as like
in the afc
um
that rivalry with the ran out with the
rams with the bengals browns steelers
and ravens
they just [ __ ] hate each other
um
it's been going on a long time the
problem with the afc east
is that the jets
dolphins and bills have just sucked for
so long
um and now the bills are good so i don't
know you need like uh
what you need is a couple of good teams
well the browns suck forever and they
still hate the steelers i don't know i
don't know what i'm talking about anyway
let's uh let's plow ahead let's do a
little bit of uh
a little bit of the uh
advertising here for this week oh look
who it is everybody old zip
[Music]
girdup
all right zip recruiter according to the
latest research
90 of employees plan to make an
enhancing the employee experience a top
priority in 2022.
they're going to enhance
plan to make enhancing the employee
experience
or you have
enhancing the employee like you're at
your job and they're going to enhance it
doesn't mean they're adding to your job
or you can have more fun at work after
all a happy workplace is the key to
attracting and keeping great employees
all i had to do was read the next
sentence who knew
sometimes the answers are just right
around the corner
and if you need to add more employees to
your team their zip
uh their matching technology helps you
find the right people for your roles
fast and right now you can try zip
recruiter for free at ziprecruiter.com
uses its powerful technology to find and
match the light uh the right candidates
up with your job then it proactively
presents these candidates to you here
they are john um you can easily review
review these
um recommended candidates and invite
your top choices to apply for your job
which encourages encourages them to
apply faster no wonder ziprecruiter is
the number one rated hiring site in the
united states based on g2 ratings
zip recruiters technology is so
effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter get
a quality candidate within the first day
find the right employees for the
workplace with zip
[Music]
try it for free at this exclusive
website ziprecruiter.com
that's
ziprecruiter.com uh b-u-r-r slash
b-u-r-r zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
[ __ ]
got the goddamn heat on
drying out the vocal cords here
screaming zip recruiter um oh look what
it is everybody movement
spelt michael vincent michael thomas
mvmt
or a few pilots michael victor michael
tango
all right
or a few liberals
um medium velvet medium
tassels um sorry
all right now i'm gonna do it for the
conservatives
uh uh me
vermont no vermont's liberal sorry
meat venison meat
titties uh valentine's day is already
around the corner and we know finding
the right gift can be stressful that's
why our friends over at movement watches
have already done the hard work for you
with a huge site-wide sale
movement
is a valentine's day favorite with
timeless watches
18
18 000 find 18 carat
18k fine jewelry pieces and special
edition styles like rare ceramic watches
and bracelets
ceramic isn't that what you make like
tiles out of if you [ __ ] break your
watch that can't be the same kind of
ceramic
um
you can save on these gifts right now
just choose a watch in a matching
accessory and get an immediate 20 off
your order plus free shipping and free
returns always
enjoy a stress-free valentine's day by
curating the perfect watch plus
accessory gift for a special discount
all in one one and done gifting made
easy ladies you gotta do this guys love
watches
all right you get him a watch and you go
downtown i think you know i think he's
gonna have a good day i forgot it's all
about you guys
you gotta get him a dainty uh
[ __ ] uh
ceramic watch
enjoy a stress-free valentine's day by
curating the perfect watch i already
said that better than chocolates better
than fly exactly chocolates are gonna
make her fat flowers will make her
sneeze
you get her a watch you'll look at it
and be like you know
he got that for me these are the gifts
that last
and they can wear every day
unless you break up with them and they
start banging someone else shop 20
off today with free shipping and free
returns by going to movement dot com
slash bur that's
mvmt.com for your most stress-free
valentine's day gifting yet
movement
uh style shouldn't break the bank join
the movement
all right there's one more here
bespoke post bespoke post
you know this winner
you can upgrade your daily routine with
bespoke post and their new seasonal
lineup of must-have
box
of awesome
collections
all right
box of awesome do not
put that on your girlfriend's
valentine's day card
you know what i love about you
sweetheart i love your box of awesome
sorry bespoke part post partners with
small businesses in emerging brands
oh bespoke partners with small
businesses now it makes sense and
emerging brands to bring you the most
unique goods every month no matter what
you're into box of awesome has you
covered
from winter cocktails to cozy threads
and camping gear essentials box of
awesome has collections for every part
of your life essentials like weekend
bags
cocktail kits health products cigar
accessories to get started take the quiz
at box of awesome.com your answers will
help them pick the right box of awesome
for you they release new boxes every
month across a ton of different
categories it's free to sign up and you
can skip a month or cancel any time each
boss costs each box costs only 45 bucks
but has over 70 dollars worth of [ __ ]
inside man sorry gear inside plus with
each buck you know it's awesome when
they call it gear
they say stuff
that's some [ __ ] knickknacks and
when they start saying gear 70 dollars
worth of gear
you know it's gonna be good stuff plus
with each box of awesome you're you're
supporting small businesses this is what
i like ninety percent of everything that
comes in your box of awesome is from a
small up-and-coming brand get twenty
percent off your first monthly box when
you sign up at box of awesome.com and
enter the code bur b-u-r-r at checkout
that's box of awesome dot com code bur
for 20 off your first box thank
the good lord we're through those things
all right
um
i just realized you know what is going
to happen all these podcasts when i'm
dead and gone
you know
if you're listening to this in the
future and i'm dead i don't want to
thank you for giving a [ __ ]
that's great
how many seasons are left are we just
down to summer
um war with russia
hey billy bear ah
god
billy bear one of my favorite characters
from the original 48 hours
if you want to see one of the greatest
acting performances of all time
as far as a brand new actor in his first
movie eddie murphy in 48 hours
in the level of drama
and comedy in that i just don't
understand why they didn't give him more
drama work eddie murphy should be unlike
his third oscar by now and billy bear
was the uh
american indian native american whatever
you're supposed to say
um partnering crime with gans
i still think that that that movie had
the best gun sound
i'm sure now that's the shit's louder
but i just love the way the gun sounded
in that movie
um
billy bear billy
you're gonna lose
um all right
heard you question why the talking heads
are stoking
a war with russia i literally thought
you were talking about the band
it was like the talking heads are out
there talking [ __ ] about who
who they met at blondie um heard you
heard you question why the talking heads
are stoking a war with russia
um
that means the i guess the leaders of
the world it has to do with a lot of
things but one way to break it down is
this the us has a lot of oil contracts
with the ukraine
see
joe biden and three other political
leaders kids getting millions for
no-show
jobs all right can i can i address that
stat there
joe biden and three other political
leaders have kids that get millions of
dollars for jobs they don't even show up
to
and now that if that is true and that's
been made public did they lose those
jobs
or does it not [ __ ] matter why you
know with all of this [ __ ] out there i
don't understand it you know what i mean
well all i can say about joe biden and
all of those political leaders just tell
them to keep doing those jobs
and not to do you know tell jokes
is you're gonna get away with it in that
sector um
all right uh so they want to they want
to keep a presence there as well as
expand putting military there instigates
russia and reinforces that us's
involvement
disrupts a pipeline russia and china are
building
why can't they build a pipeline
we could all blow each other up we
already proved that this isn't going to
go anywhere
all these talking heads they're just
they're not doing anything i think they
all [ __ ] hang out on that epstein
island
afterwards you know what i mean
after they get everybody all stirred up
and then they just bang [ __ ]
whatever they're into and then they go
back and they act like they don't like
each other i think it's all i think it's
like wrestling
um russia doesn't want to invade the
ukraine uh they just want to keep closer
political and business ties with the
ukraine
than the us
pres oh so the ukraine's a little the
hot chick on the block
all right come on ukraine let's let's
try to work this
president of ukraine recently told biden
he didn't want any us military
intervention
the guy is probably between a rock and a
hard place money coming in from the u.s
but proximity to russia means he has to
respect both
no he doesn't he has our nuclear weapons
behind him we're never going to use them
they're never going to use theirs
what he should do is these girls should
go to russia and be like hey you know uh
not for nothing the u.s is giving me
this maybe if you give me that you know
all of a sudden i like your little furry
hat there russian guy that's what they
should do um you can watch all the new
stations
um and read the new york times and
they're giving all the reasons as to why
we need to support our ukrainian
brothers as if they give a [ __ ] i know
it's so stupid
the whole thing is so [ __ ] stupid
most people can't find the ukraine on a
[ __ ] map
i couldn't remember the name of the
country for some reason i remember the
name of the capital kiev i remember
during the bush administration neil
young did a free speech tour because he
was against intervention in the middle
east and he was getting heat for it glad
he is staying away from this and
focusing on comedians who interviewed
doctors for three hours
you know he's old man maybe he wants to
pick a smaller fight
all right
bank robbery stories
uh
all right bank robbery stories dear
billy covet balls
i've been a huge fan of the podcast your
stand up f is for family
and you as an actor for years now thank
you so much look at you
that's the kind of support i need man
uh my wife owns a bank
my wife's family owns a bank get the
[ __ ] out of here do they have like
candelabras in their house
and [ __ ] taxidermied [ __ ] animals
on the wall
oh that's amazing they own a bank
my wife did now did they choose you do
you also come from a a wealthy family
was it some sort of [ __ ] ceremony
with like robes and a [ __ ]
virgin blood and [ __ ] my wife's family
owns a bank and i've heard some pretty
wild s
sorties
i think stories is what you were trying
to say about successful and unsuccessful
robbery attempts oh they say no robbery
oh this is fantastic this is a whole new
segment
anybody here ever have somebody come in
and try to rob their store i want to
hear the [ __ ] stories this is
incredible
somebody coming in risking their own
freedom
to get what's in the [ __ ] store and
some poor man or woman in the [ __ ]
store
now worrying if they're gonna lose their
life only tell me ones that just are
funny i don't want to hear
sad we had a real sad one out here some
guy just came in and just stabbed this
poor woman who was just just sitting
there working a job man whole life ahead
of her [ __ ] horrific i don't wanna
hear [ __ ] this is a fun funny
ignorant [ __ ] podcast all right keep
keep it light people
all right
anyway you talking about the teller
handing the note back to the robber to
um to telling him essentially to go [ __ ]
himself on the thursday edition of the
podcast reminding me of one of the
unsuccessful attempts at one of their
branches yeah i was talking about how
you know you can rob a bank with a note
and they're just supposed to assume that
you have a weapon and let the
authorities handle it and i was thinking
like you know if you had degenerate
gamblers work as tellers they'd never
give up the money
you know they'd always take the gamble
maybe you could save some [ __ ] you
know getting robbed i don't know it's a
stupid idea of course it was it came
from me
anyway here's a guy's story here guy
walks in and asks one of the tellers for
the cash and the branch manager walks
out
and pretty much tells the guy not today
i've already had a stressful day and i
don't have time for this [ __ ] you need
to get the [ __ ] out the guy took his
note and walked right back out the door
he came in
oh my god
that is [ __ ] amazing and then the guy
didn't go to jail can you imagine if
that guy turned his life around i bet he
tells that story and nobody believes him
i came in with a note and the guy said
not today i've already i've already had
enough stress i don't have time for this
[ __ ] now you can get the [ __ ] out
geez then that right there is the
[ __ ] branch manager of the year
that's the [ __ ]
was dirty harry's name jack callahan
but you know what happened with dirty
harry his partners were always getting
killed so that guy's eventually gonna
get a teller killed anyway at another
branch the teller gave the guy the money
and the police found him
and got into a chase during the chase
the robber was driving unusually erratic
and when he wrecked they discovered the
reason for it was because he was trying
to shove the money up his ass to hide it
oh my god
i i don't believe that one
oh my god
i mean
i mean that's how high the stakes are
he's literally going like
if i get caught i'm gonna go to jail
and i'm gonna get raped in the ass what
do i want in my ass
somebody else's dick
or a bag of dirty cash
cash can't tell a story man [ __ ] it
i'll take what's behind door number two
um the police ended up calling and
asking if the bank wanted the poop
money back because it was recovered they
declined
not sure what ever happened to that cash
uh you know what happened to it
you know exactly what [ __ ] happened
to it
the [ __ ] cops took it down to one of
those power wash things
[ __ ] sprayed it
air-dried it and they threw a kegger um
all right talking talking about it my
dude talking about
it my dude
yo bill my dude first all i love that
black people have given you white
peoples a new you use for the word dude
which is really all y'alls
it was sitting there all along my dude
oh i guess that's how black people i
like my dude is funny it doesn't sound
right coming out of my mouth and you
know what i stay in my lane
wait a minute i married a black woman i
can't say i stay in my lane
[Music]
all right i veered off a little bit okay
on to it heard you give up on uh you
give up on caring about covet [ __ ] last
week and i want to tell you
i ain't been talking about covered [ __ ]
to anyone for a while now about a year
and a half ago i saw my doctor who was a
real person and it isn't an office and
uses a stethoscope
and has cotton balls in a jar a real ass
doctor out here outside of atlanta flesh
and blood he told me point blank
them shitty masks didn't work
um he said i could find the good ones
but the regular ass cloth mats my credit
union was handing out didn't do it
didn't do nothing yeah i mean who
doesn't know that
there's massive gaps on the top and the
bottom
um and guess what he even explained why
i'm a licensed electrician but it made
sense
to me my dude he was looking out for me
to make sure i didn't have a false sense
of confidence in them things he wasn't
telling me the vid was fake my dude a
few days later i told two friends
who happened to be white women about
masks and they was yelling at me
no jesus christ they weren't karen's
were they i was just looking out because
they showed up to a place with the mask
that said gucci in sequence oh god yeah
yeah why now let me ask you a question
why did you think that they were gonna
listen to you
you know
like i i felt like that was a major
character flaw during this pandemic
where
you're such a self-involved person that
you had to have some sort of flair on
your mask
you know what i mean to show that you're
different and i still just need to stand
out need to have some sort of focus or
show that i have money
anyway then they started coming at me
like they they was nurses and doctors
and asking why they ain't heard that i
ain't lying my dude now they are saying
on tv what my doctor said almost two
years ago two years for that [ __ ] they
hit the twitter my dude this is why i
been questioning stuff but like i said
just said to myself
but like i just said to myself that's
the end
thanks and stay lotioned i will
i absolutely will um
yeah well you know
i mean
medicine is also getting so much [ __ ]
[ __ ] acting like they you know they're
not responsible for keeping seven
billion people alive every [ __ ] day
which they do tremendously
and i just feel like uh there's just
something about [ __ ] morons
they just think they're smart and then
they just like to just point out
they just like to point out where people
that are you know
specialists in something from cops to
doctors
athletes everybody everybody comedian
everybody's just getting [ __ ] [ __ ] on
yeah they shouldn't have told that joke
well why do you [ __ ] do that as i'm
[ __ ] on [ __ ] coaches this week
you know we all [ __ ] do it
we all do it i still believe like listen
they're not gonna get everything right
but they get way more right than they
get wrong
and i am alive today because of doctors
if not i would have died of a ruptured
[ __ ] appendix all right so i have no
problem with doctors and i don't care
that they work at more of a snail's pace
than these uh shoot from the hip guys
who [ __ ] leave mainstream medicine of
course you can [ __ ] have new
information you don't have any [ __ ]
checks and balances anymore
but i also know that the other thing is
[ __ ] you know it's corrupt whatever
fda has former people from the
pharmaceutical companies as their
members and they pass [ __ ] and i don't
know whatever who gives a [ __ ] i don't
care
okay
um
i'm still alive so somebody's doing
something right all right shadow
dictator
uh dear bat [ __ ] bill
that's another good one
billy bear batshit bill covet balls bill
there's some good ones this week all
right so we've been doing this thing uh
if you were a dictator
uh what you would be doing um all right
if i were a dictator
i would call all the shots as a shadow
dictator i'd have some pasty pretend
patsy sorry
it's my own [ __ ] low self-esteem i
thought you were setting me up to take
the fall i'd have some patsy pretend to
be
dictator for the public while i make all
of the decisions i would
compartmentalize the chain of command so
no one knows who is really in charge
that's one way to keep the military or
anyone from taking me out if my patsy
was taken out i just have some
replacements hanging around
there's a lot of holes in that but i
understand what you're doing if your
patsy gets taken out and everybody
around him thinks he's the guy they're
going to be fighting with whoever's
taking him over and they're going to
take out whatever security that guy has
which is also your security what you
should do is when the patsy gets taken
out you walk away with all the [ __ ]
money they thought the patsy had
and then you walk away like hannibal
lecter at the end of [ __ ] uh
uh good will hunting whatever that
[ __ ] movie was called silence to the
lamps
that's how i would do it uh
by the way isn't that what politicians
are
they just you know we're not gonna say
we have dictators you have all these
[ __ ] underpaid people and then they
all make zillions of dollars and i guess
their kids work in the ukraine without
having to show up and make a million
dollars a year
all i know is they all end up with a
mansion on [ __ ] martha's vineyard and
they're all amazing at the stock market
let's start if i ever see a house of
representative or senator
senator you got any stock tips you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
first thing i do is replace isn't
continuing first thing i do is replace
all cars with self-driving vehicles
because people can't drive for [ __ ]
except for me i'd collect all the
classic and exotic cars so i could drive
a different one each day of the year i'd
abolish the stock market because [ __ ] it
oh by the way dude how are you going to
be a shadow dictator if you're the only
guy driving around in these exotic cars
this guy's not gonna last man i'd make
health care education and shelter a
basic right and fund those things so
that people wouldn't revolt
i then build new cities by calculating
how much resources are available per
person and limit the population in each
city accordingly
voting would be done online but people
would be able to vote on things i would
allow like putting rick james on the 20
bill then i would go have a beer and
think of what else i could do peace and
go [ __ ] yourself
i wonder if they're away if you just
exposed everything that these other
[ __ ] are doing there's no way to do
it it's just human beings are just
we go after the dollar because you got
the dollar then you get the [ __ ]
um if i were a dictator
hey billy red scare
i guess that's a comment on my looks
that one kind of hurt i'm not gonna lie
to you
um sorry i was looking it didn't really
bother me i was just looking down to see
how much time i had done all right i'm
sick of
kumbaya dances with the wolves dictators
writing in about how they'd murdered the
bankers and give everyone a puppy here's
what i do i like this go against the
grain first and foremost i'm in it for
me
i'd rise to power by making different
groups of people hate each other and
while they're busy fighting each other
i'd seize the high office
not an original idea but it's tried and
true it works i'd immediately start
wearing a military uniform full of
metals i didn't earn and i drive around
in a ferrari
bulletproof bulletproof you got to do
the scarface thing with that first once
i've consolidated power i'd ban social
media and liquidate their ceos
i'd milk every last drop out of this
country and when i couldn't borrow
another buck from the bank or buy
another bottle of booze i'd light a
match but in the meantime me and my
friends would have a good [ __ ] time
bill if you support me your daughter
will be getting
a
la ferrari for her sweet 16. if you
don't support me that's fine you'll be
pulling my rickshaw until your freckled
ass collapses on the street thanks and
go [ __ ] yourself
ah that's great
fantastic well once again
congratulations to the cincinnati
bengals
um
condolences to the kansas city chiefs
fans of the kansas city chiefs coming up
short
um still had a great season you know you
did have a great season because
everybody wrote you off and you damn
near got back to the dance again
and congratulations to the 49ers who i
[ __ ] wrote off all goddamn year and
look at you look at you look how close
you came
um
we're a minute away
or so whatever i don't know how much
time was left when you had the last have
the lead i don't know
last five minutes anyway um that is it
who do you like in the super bowl
um
i gotta tell you i think joe burrows
just got the magic
i think he's got the magic and i think
the rams i didn't like
i didn't like the coaching i just
thought he got a little [ __ ] cute i
just think as a stand-up comedian i
would have made some some different
choices
no they're both great coaches um
i don't know what a straight what a
story huh matthew stafford huh he's
playing for the [ __ ] lions he never
[ __ ] he never complains
he's just out there giving it his all
and he just said he wanted to go to a
place and have a chance to [ __ ] win
and now he's in the super bowl it's
gonna be [ __ ] amazing
um
i can't tell you this what is so amazing
about sports
is that if tom brady actually retired
i'm not sure if he did or not but if he
does retire
the void that it
i thought it was going to create
because i was immediately sad like wow
that's it i just i saw his last game
thank god
that uh joe burrow comes along and i'll
get to see mahomes versus joe burrow
hoping
that that's gonna be uh
like all those great brady verse [ __ ]
peyton manning
the eli manning games those were [ __ ]
amazing games
um
has there ever been a brother
combination in the nfl
that was there's no way that they were
that successful they won four super
bowls between the two of them
went to six
super bowls
brother
qb's in the nfl
all right let's see how many
the two brothers peyton eli manning are
synonymous with football in the 2000's
the hasselbecks
the mannings
there's a castle a couple of hasslebacks
josh and luke mccown
i don't know where that is at um [ __ ]
amazing anyways all right that's the
podcast for this week thank you
everybody for listening uh my apologies
to everybody in fantasy springs i'm
gonna make it up for you i'm gonna be
doing a [ __ ] i'm gonna be going off i
cannot wait to get back on stage
and uh spew out all of my [ __ ]
ignorance that i've been writing while
i've been home
um
playing guitar again having a good time
dusting off the old malcolm [ __ ]
chords that i used to know
and uh just having a great time um
and uh that's it thank you guys you know
for coming out to the shows and all of
that [ __ ] that is it
and uh i can't believe there's only one
more week of [ __ ] football
where does it go unbelievable all right
that's the podcast go [ __ ] yourselves
and i'll check in on you on thursday